Ronni not to bust your balls but but I
guess I'm gonna what so Gary tells me he
goes out and he says to you hey there's
a whole bunch of Dunkin Donuts here who
where'd they come from and I said I
don't know they were and this people are
supposed to leave a note when they put
them but but what I'm saying yeah we
here at 5:00 in the morning then don't
eat them nobody ate them we put them on
the side so throw them in the garbage we
don't know where they're from you're
supposed to know where they're from
nobody opened the box right nobody took
any right nobody so once you learn that
they're supposed to leave a note
cuz you've had this discussion with him
before if you see something that doesn't
belong do something when I when I asked
you I thought you were gonna say I don't
know I'm going to find out I'm gonna ask
what did you ask around know what's
going on do you check out are you all
night fine aren't you concerned aren't
you concerned about this yeah are you
high my mind is in Vegas yeah is your
mind in Vegas Chris Wildings out there
yelling that you shouldn't be doing
security all right let's hear from you
of course he's checked out what do you
mean what do I mean what do you mean
he's not doing his job and he doesn't
care he gives zero [ __ ] okay Chrissy
I mean who brought the doughnuts and you
wouldn't have found out you wouldn't
care let's say it wasn't poison Detroit
is just a weirdo who like rub his dick
all over it for us to eat what is going
you know with the problem the security
guy or not he claims he is and he always
wants to be like a cop yeah and he's
like I'm like what a great opportunity
great job you know this this came up
before he told me it's an entrance
it was hunt down
the person who bought the food and
determined whether it's safe for the
staff to eat right you think he'd be
excited but there's usually so little to
do back here in the morning there aren't
that many people on the staff so it's
easy to go around you know there's not
that many people here at 5:00 running I
generally felt because this is I believe
the third time this has come up in six
months I thought you would have said I
thought you didn't know and I would I
would have cut you that then I thought
you would have gone you know what I'm
gonna go ask around and see where they
came from I did is Rama DP what did you
ask
I asked Steve who's here early one
person Sammy said they were here when I
got here already not the guy he was he
watches ray Donovan the FBI problem get
into it be an investigative kind of guy
let's see I've eliminated the Unabomber
so it's safe
Ronny cares leave a note Ronny cares if
you [ __ ] with his food if you [ __ ] with
his
yeah you got that right nobody knows who
touched Ronnie's bagel how do you not
know who touched your baby
what do you mean your security I went
out to the store other guys they went
out to the kitchen to get a drink go
ahead I come back bagels all unwrap the
paper brows are gone
what is the bagel sitting on there was
one little napkin sitting on top Ronnie
nobody [ __ ] with your food you [ __ ]
Oh
I be livid but everyone else in the
compound know you're supposed to be
protecting and by the way how safe is a
note anyway anyone can write double
check like I'm not one yeah I mean I
don't know I was the security guy I keep
saying is - Ronnie investigate nobody
touch these people I'm fine you know
it's gonna be an interesting year man
biker it's gonna be a lot of this good
12 months of zero [ __ ] Ron